good morning believe nation today's
message is listen to the whispers over
to you Steven Spielberg when you have a
dream and the dream isn't something you
dream then it happens that dream is
something you never knew was going to
come into your life dreams always come
from behind you not not right between
your eyes it's teks up on you but when
you have a dream it doesn't often come
at you screaming in your face
this is who you are this is what you
must be for the rest of your life
sometimes a dream almost whispers and
I've always said to my kids the hardest
thing to listen to your instincts your
human personal intuition always whispers
it never shouts very hard to hear so you
have to every day of your lives be ready
to hear what whispers in your ear it
very rarely shouts and if you can listen
to the whisper and if it tickles your
heart and it's something you think you
want to do for the rest of your life
then that is going to be what you do for
the rest of your life and we will
benefit from everything you do so what
do you think
I think it's profound listening to the
whispers a Sookie I like to call them
hugs from heaven thank you the reason I
say that is because kitchen chat is a
way of honoring my late father he was an
incredible gourmet home chef and my
biggest regret in life is not going in
the kitchen with him and learning how to
cook so this is a tangible way to honor
his legacy and just being here with you
today is listening to the whispers like
a hug from heaven to be able to share
his story and his legacy and his joy of
cooking with you and your audience Wow
that's an awesome tribute I think for me
there's we always have these voices
inside our head whether it's like our
own voice or message from your father or
whoever it is we have this voice that
tells us to do things but then we don't
often have the boldness to follow
through on it
like I should go to say some way and I
should meet that person on stage that I
respect so much but then you get there
and you cow down right you lose the guts
and so there's a reason why that voice
is telling you to do something and I
think having the fortitude to feel the
fear like it's not don't be afraid it's
fueled of fear and do it anyway like go
out and do it like it's in there for a
reason listen to it because otherwise
you're gonna go home and be kicking
yourself like I said I was gonna do it
and I didn't do it and now I'm upset at
myself and I always do this to myself
right and so the next time you get that
little thing inside your head just go
out and try even if you're scared go out
and try and I think be bold with those
whispers I love it
so the question today today is who has
whispered to you lately and what action
are you going to take right now because
you've listened to the whisper I like it
leave in the comments below we will join
in the discussion so thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso